probably seen flatlands hana-chan I have
seen Flatliners I was five years old and
I don't remember a thing about it hey
keep my name is Greg Alba and I'm John
are you guys ready to enter the
afterlife yeah find out what's on the
other side
Flatliners latin liner is number 1 2017
get high on death now from my
understanding according to 24 hours
keeper Sutherlands is like a soft reboot
does it handle yeah he's in this and you
said it's more of a sequel than a remake
ok but if it was a sequel it be called
flat liner or Flatliners - there's a
plan not just the same exact time you
flatline her just John you're asking me
who directed the original has been the
original plan which truly odd the
greatest director of all time I'm
talking about Joel Schumacher oh [ __ ]
that's right the shoe made passable cult
films in the nineties yeah
number 23 I always tell the original one
so this came out the year we were born
oh man so I haven't seen the original
since we released its 1995 original eyes
first open now I had the VHS copy of it
really was it a good quality I'll be
totally Keefer Oliver Platt
Oh Baconator Robert don't drop in
[Music]
our animals I am mildly surprised but
offer exactly midnight basements the
global city I would like you to stop my
heart you give it one minute and then
you bring me back okay now with what we
said photo jokes I'm an honest and brush
what happens after we die the only way
to find out is to see for ourselves
we conducted an experiment to see white
light it was more like a little energy
how does it mean piano know what
complains and rewired I'm gonna charging
200 it's a good day to die right girl
from the original three minutes Danny
only due to what I'm saying it's a
competitive a lot of medical I do know
most picturesque Annette
[Music]
45 happening time this is going Chris I
wanna open the door
[Music]
[Music]
what about our coming about
[Music]
I'll page bid enough for a hard candy uh
yeah I mean that's one of those like
what genre is it really yeah technically
oh cool oh yeah yeah that looks really
cool
it looks it looks pretty pretty sweet
actually now I said I don't really
remember the original
no but there's a lot of similar beat
sheets in here that I remember from the
original uh like Kiefer Sutherland I
believe is the character who he's the
one who has his med student he like the
Ellen Page those were you got to do you
got a [ __ ] agender anyways he's the one
who like has the med students and that
makes sense you know like we're watching
the trailer a bunch of hot-looking med
students and I'm like the original cast
was Kevin Bacon and Julia Roberts in for
the hot-looking 90s guest 2 for med
student hey only only sexy people get
into not yeah it's similar beats I'm
noticing like oh I want you to
flatlining
are you crazy and then they do it and
then this another student who's like
okay I want to go and then everyone's
doing it and it's like kind of fun but
then some dark [ __ ] starts really
happening they start seeing visions if
it's honoring their the context of the
original of what I remember like I said
I left in this movie in like 20 years
they have like visions that were linked
to traumatic incidents of their past
okay and they would start seeing it in
present-day some past few years it's
sort of coming back and haunting them
like their visionary tales and stuff the
trailer isn't really allude to something
like that happening is more like they're
stepping into the afterlife and them how
they come back with abilities or some
[ __ ] doing or just playing the p.m. an
hour yeah yeah well I'm a little curious
about physics or going to get home or
what happens when they flatline and what
are they seeing or developing yeah
what's the updated version were they
bringing that quick I feel like with a
concept like this they're only so many
directions you can run in with it so I
guess the soft reboot idea I don't think
is a bad idea a lot of that movie was
they flatline and I'm not just I'm not
like kind of review the original I'm
just saying a lot of what I remember
Thai movies here in this again this kind
of set is a moment Oh both are always
you know as a distributor innovation say
I'm gonna be the time so a dollar yeah
there's a lot of that in this trailer to
a man means like it looks like there's a
pretty good on so like despite the time
control like ridiculously sexy like it
doesn't look like a pretty good ensemble
I got like the little character beats
and stuff and it looks like in those
flashes I mean Ellen Page is a great
actress I don't really I'm fantastic in
anything
I'm sure lady price this freak out and
break down moments are going to be are
going to be pretty yet you know and
Diego Luna man I won't be able be a low
blow I love Diego but I think it's so
cool and I've seen so many movies
opposite of Mexican han solo I've seen
him in so many I really recognize a lot
of the other cast I'm also I'm kind of
glad that I Kiefer Sutherland is not in
the tree oh he'll be in the next I hope
he's not he'll be in the net was like
shadow I'm at the end of the trailer the
nineties ones kind of a physic is a cult
film and nowadays and I I think the one
thing that I heard about it if I recall
correctly is it has this really cool
concept of stepping into the afterlife
but it doesn't really go all out with
that it doesn't fully take advantage of
its altered world premise this movie
doesn't look like it's really pushing it
either it doesn't look like it's a
generic it looks kind of like a generic
remake to me honestly so this looks like
maybe a solid well-made thriller with
some interesting visuals of now you can
amp up the visual aesthetic you can amp
up crazy scary visual thrills well
that's something I am curious about they
showed a couple of those things but just
like what did you see and they have
those kind of abstract images of lights
and things and now that we have more
ability to show things yeah that's
something I'm very much wondering about
is if there are going to be at least
sequences in this movie to take bigger
advantage that
because we have you know updated text to
maybe make it look good or you know are
we gonna keep away from doing that
because like at a certain point you're
imagining an unimaginable thing yeah you
know like a pretty much unimaginable
thing and so like it's hard to show
something like that sometimes it is more
effective just a hint you know oh yeah
totally so that's it that's a surprise
I'm looking forward to finding out this
also seems like the kind of movie where
like you'll get to know the ensemble
over time so even if it kind of looks
like is looks sort of like a reboot of
flatline I still feel like those
potential for for the cast or to you
know be charming and to bring you in
because it seems to have all the
elements sci-fi or psychological
thriller and it seems to be doing all
three of those elements pretty well
honestly look I might feel initial
feeling of yes looks like a
straightforward remake the original
flounders yeah it still looks like the
genre elements are being honored very
well and it's biolistic Lee shots a note
ography looks very excellent here the
visual effects aren't bad
yeah and Helen page is a great actress
diego luna who are the other guys in
this movie i haven't even heard i know i
wonder if this is going to become one of
those movies where they're like there
was an experiment they did back in the
early night yeah that's probably going
to you try it but with your intent
that's my keeper so this is gonna walk
in there all don't do it you're gonna
hear footsteps shadow keep gonna front
behind they're all turning who is it I
hope he'll step in the shadow there I
hope he shows up just in one cameo just
like when somebody dies they see his
face man oh this chick oh she's one of
the hot chicks from The Vampire Diaries
oh boy Nina Dobrev and return of xander
cage that swear I actually know her from
good I wanted to see both The Perks of
Being a Wallflower and the final girl
now she's beautiful she's born one year
before the originals she's probably
going to mention that in an interview
this is the first movie ever so good
where is the hot boy where's that yeah
where's serious that guy looks James
Gordon he's got a British Black Mirror
he is an episode of Black Mirror who
Ryan pounds
a lot of TV my dad loved weird sci-fi
films growing up that's why I saw
Flatliners and another one that I saw
around the same time as William Hurt or
Jeff Bridges
it's called altered states and that film
[Music]
that's what I'm going take you live a
demo that movie it's not exactly the
same concept but it deals with like you
know project with the mind and diving
into my next story and now it's really
tripping and really insane and I just
there's one thing I want you're gonna
remake this do that go balls-out my
feeling on any any soft reboot or
otherwise is definitely to make it your
own you know take it off in a direction
that maybe it didn't go or you know I
think movies like the crazies where it's
like oh we can update this and there's a
reason like it didn't achieve its full
potential first hand I've seen some some
things in the comments you complaining
about the ensemble that's a fair point
when we're rebooting all these older
properties you know that that relied at
least partway on the strength of their
cast I think you do have to
well the cast of the originals like yeah
and that's it William Baldwin but you
know that that's the thing I'm
cautiously curious about with something
like this because you've got at least
one actress I think it's terrific and
the rest of these guys I just haven't
seen much those are the things I wonder
about when we come back and what are
they going to live up and sometimes I
feel like the chances oh you cast a
bunch of people who aren't as huge as as
at least the people are that we remember
and sometimes that's good in sometimes
it's bad I'm consciously optimistic
about this I guess because like even
though I thought it was a long trailer
it I still liked most of this stuff I
was you know I'm only I'm really curious
about the things they're going to add
with the effects of this experiment
basically well the 90 is one I mean it's
kind of a silly film to not to say all
cult films are silly but this one like
they kind of go down
a little bit of silly territory and I
can imagine what it might be like
especially not the Joel Schumacher only
makes silly things but like I can kind
of approximate in my mind what that
movie like yeah might feel like I
remember the 90s I don't know I mean I
feel like with a movie like that you
kind of have to have at least a bit of
personality because it's a weird like
like the concept of this is semis down
to earth and it's also a little
ridiculous it's weird like I can kind of
hear somebody going together doing this
death experiment you die for a couple
minutes you come back different people
are hopping on board i flatline like
we're gonna fly hold on sign me up
I'm yes man I'm doing me a bro I'll go
on the table there how to do reaction
videos byline you can die come back
whole new skill I learned up ladies okay
what do you want to learn today I don't
know well we're gonna kill you but I
like the matrix with more work motherís
beard subscribe is a real reject hey
click that notification about that John
Humphrey Twitter and Instagram is his
birthday yesterday
what happy birthday to ya
Oh check out our exclusive perks and
content over at patreon coms watch the
real rejects join us we'll show you
pictures and stuff a lot more III shows
are going to catch up on video games are
our specialty